*ballon qui éclate*
Enorme cette intro !
Lady and gentleman : Welcome to Bio Ing Redintion !
Je vais peut être ouvrir une chaîne youtube en anglais moi...
Avec un peu de chance j'aurais 2 abonnés !
Les amis ce jeu est extrêmement glauque, MAIS il a att-ir-é mon attention
Attention pas intention à chaque fois je fais l'erreur
Alors, en gros on va jouer un médecin, si vous voulez on a un corps humain devant-nous qui aura cette forme là !
Ok c'est à dire qu'on euh voit l'intérieur du corps humain d'accord, le cœur, les poumons, les organes tous ça on connaît bien !
SVT niveau 5 ème TMTC.
Donc en gros soit le corps est malade et on choisit la vie, c'est à dire que l'on va devoir le soigner.  Soit le corps et en pleine santé et on choisit la mort c'est à dire qu'on va devoir l'empoisonner, jusqu'à causer le DÉCÈS du mec !
C'est glauque ,-,
On va faire les deux et on va commencer par la vie
parce que moi j'adore l'amour plus que la haine, donc on choisit l'amour, et après on choisira la haine.
Ok choix du service, on peut aller qu'en faculté de médecine, pas le level pour aller en clinique ou en hôpital, c'est pas grave,
c'est pas grave, c'est des choses qui arrivent
On est en internat : votre premier cas, faites bonne impression." t’inquiètes pas !
Nommer votre patient !
"J'ai mal"
Choix de la difficulté modérée, modérée.
Grave ou mortel ça va être hyper dur. On va mettre modérée
On est des médecins mais tranquille tranquille.
Oh c'est bon c'est pas parce que t'es en première année de médecine,
Que tu peux te croire au-dessus oh oh !
En fait si tu peux carrément te croire au-dessus
En gros on a ici le corps de la personne on peux regarder son système circulatoire, respiratoire
digestif, osseux, nerveux, rénal, immunitaire et musculaire.
Et là la moitié des gens on déjà quitté la vidéo
C'est normal !
Des fois il y a des petits trucs comme ça qui apparaissent
Et en fait on peut les récolter
Ok
Et ça nous donne des "Points bio".
Vous voyer ici j'en ai quatre
On voit ici qu'il a un problème au système nerveux,
Et qu'il a un problème circulatoire mec.
Alors, carte bio ici on a la liste de ses symptômes
Il a paralysie, il a des sautes d'humeur
des maux de tête, de la fatigue, des vertiges, des courbatures
Et des gonflements des jambes.
Il a clairement un problème au cerveau.
On va tout de suite aller voir son cerveau. On va lui faire
un examen neurologique. Une IRM
Une IRM mec, comme ça c'est la totale.
Merde ! J'ai pas récolté assez de points bio putain !
ou alors j'ai fait exprès pour illustrer a combien les point bio c'est important
Ou alors, j'ai fait exprès pour illustrer à quel point les points bio, c'est important.
Là, on va essayer de trouver ce qu'il a.
pour moi c'est un truc au cerveau c'est clair, c'est clair et nette
Écoutez déjà une fois j'ai jouer a "Docteur Maboul"
écouter déjà une fois j'ai jouer a docteur maboul
A partir de là, je peux te dire que je peux me dém*rder, hein !
A partir de là, je peux te dire que je peux me dém*rder,hein !
Mais pour moi, clairement, le mec a des vertiges,
Mais pour moi, clairement, le mec a des vertiges, des sauts d'humeur et des maux de têtes. C'est forcément un truc au cerveau.
des sauts d'humeur, et des mals de tête
c'est forcément un truc au cerveau, ou alors je suis une merde.
Ou alors j'suis une m*rde.
Résultat du test positif, positif, positif.
Résultats du test : positif, positif, positif. P*tain, on a trouvé trois trucs.
Putain on a trouvé trois trucs
Il a un accident vasculaire et cérébral, un caillot sanguin et de l'hypertension..
Ok, alors les traitements...
C'est un problème au cœur.
C'est exactement ce que j'ai dis. Flashback :
"C'est forcément un truc au cerveau. Ou alors je suis une merde"
On est d'accord.
Ici, on a donc les traitements possibles.
Donc on va lui filer une Thrombolyse
ça coûte très cher, on oublie on va lui filer des diurétiques. Donc comme vous pouvez le voir
il y a plusieurs traitements possibles pour chaque symptôme, chaque symptômes se soigne !
Nouveau symptôme !Tremblements
Oh putaiin de merde là!
Je peux lui souscrire la thrombolyse C'est parti!
Yes!
Et maintenant on va résoudre le problème d'hypertension et on sera pas mal. ça coûte 6 allez!
Donc la on voit que le traitement est en cours et le but c'est d'arrivé à 100% de guérison et on n'est qu'à 7 % mec.
putaiin on va lui filer mec un nombre de médocs à bouffer c'est terrible. Nouveau symptôme Pulsations cardiaques irrégulières
Putainnnnn son système circulatoire
prend tellement cher
faut qu'on résolve le problème. On peut maintenant résoudre le dernier problème qui est l'hypertension
en lui subscrivant bien sur un abonnement et
des alpha-bloquants c'est partie
prescrire c'est en cours son état va
bien évidemment s'améliorer
fantastique excellent divin
ça peut être parkinson ah oui il a
des tremblements mec c'est peut être parkinson
le mec il a tout le problème du monde
c'est génial il cumule tout *tousse* ohlala
on va lui faire une analyse de sang mec c'est un truc bateau ça il faut le faire ça
putain c'est horrible! regardez sa vie baisse quoi c'est terrible
j'ai pas envie qu'il meurt, je veux continuer à le sauver. ah nouveau symptôme anxiété
c'est désormais la question c'est la
sauce écologique et surtout après une
session de la voie à la réhabilitation
des quais et des bateaux vers le bas
avec on va tous été allègrement ap la
suite appris
c'est parti et ensuite antidépresseur
au démarrage de l'étude pas une
occasion aussi d autres sans stress
chronique pour les bébés
d'antidépresseurs rôle précis ballon
au palais pour les presser de finale
là-bas on va demander à qui sait
attendre marché et va vivre à cabris
côté du sud
on est jamais à l'abri en europe
autrement plus difficile
l'état d'urgence régional a été
admis dans un état qui veut pas de
porter mes tympans suis reparti sobeys
j'ai mal les mots sur les terrains
depuis son adoption en charente 1 % plus
rapide que pensent-elles sans jamais
nous sommes rapides plus tard la merde
sa mère la mère que tu peux avoir
quelques pas de la métropole le maroc
à bordeaux wendel départ titane
il avait trop lourdes pertes je suis
tellement content allez allez mon gars
ça valait pas mal avec un brutal coup
de calgon tabac avec l'idée qu'il
étudiera les relances provence provence
les autres c'est un papa le trafic ratp
était de collecter des fonds destinés
à convertir les restes à base de
pommes de terre à haïti le 24 avril à
paris et pourquoi
quant à 14 h
mais pas de quoi décourager pas étude
parue dans la cathédrale elle a
réintégré leur entourage lors du
grand patronat et là une démence de la
guerre ou la partie quant à lui la
balle de bris à tous les trois des
membres des conseils des trucs qui
supervise la pâte à sel
malheureusement j'ai tout allait de
travers
cet atelier était à son chevet pour le
motiver égaré vidéo de baten kaitos
même temps tout va bien il a soutenu la
demande au cours des nuits que du coup
ça m'a fait qu'elle ait tous qui
regardent avec appétit l'avicca
je veux du traité de ce compte-là
halal a démenti jeudi tous les
traitements contre des fantômes qui
affecte thermomètre baisse notable dans
le cadre des marchandages salutaire
d'une part les quelques heures semaine
pour beaucoup la vie
beaucoup de malades et de laboratoires
pour garder le ballon dévié par le
gardien
en regard des règles du permis à un
endroit où il est
non
cet été
rapport d'autopsié du système nerveux
dumas s'est effondrée entre la cousine
maladie de parkinson les trois gp corona
pas réussi à le sauver dans la
matapédia malabata n'avons pas trouvé
de quoi pourrait-on dire tant d'efforts
et que je sois ministre
c'est quoi de faire de moi de tête de
vertiges saut d'humeur douleurs à
l'estomac douleur rougeur gonflement des
jambes capable de circulation futur
incertain politique à son égard
d'accorder laquelle on va traiter de
cette partie d'accord avec une victoire
pour le peuple de leur côté les deux
pays tels le domaine des dauphins pour
l'étude
elles sont aidées à se soigner
gauthier ensuite on va s'occuper un peu
son cerveau il a des douleurs à
l'estomac et d'autres plus calmes du
stress chronique or aux affaires une
mêlée une électro
ça a été un match serré capendu
correctement nous apportons fait bien
plus que la paire de la fécafoot a fait
le père fayard blaireau savoir le
terrain il a un gros problème au niveau
du coeur du patient à la vie
voir pour avoir fait partie du top 10
tomas vie de merde la tripartite un
temps dégagé offerte aux petits
pâtés paquette
metal gear une chaudière à gaz ça
c'est sûrement une hypertension sont un
peu avant d'entamer des justes jusqu'aux
points des bruins et verglas dans des
études en médecine estime que google
télérama les verrait bien la ducati
positive barrages n'est pas mais je sais
qu'il a un truc avec moi qui la
maladière ouattara la ps3
au québec c'est avant tout un geste qui
risque de ne pas être capable de
produire une part de leur candidature de
torture ou de dévoiler les détails des
contre-indications de la maladie de la
retraite
l'étape est parfaitement capable de
garder le ballon pour la tête avant
d'être performant pour le départ de
l'affairé
à r alors qu'il était en fait je suis
de nature humaine je suis plus doués
pour tuer quelqu'un puis pour le sauver
c'est ce qu'on va voir objectif celui
qui a décidé
les cadets b mon pote
lebedev ont investi la place pour m
les gens n'ont pas gagné
à ce jeu vidéo devant des abonnés
l'auteur du livre pop-up de la main d'or
c'était à prévoir des retards sont à
prévoir vendredi la garde contre les
dérives autoritaires du côlon ensuite
un emploi dans des structures
horizontales attaquent sur tous les
fronts le bip-bip musculaire les
militaires tous les bénévoles de
l'amicale de la forme d'ovni il possède
actuellement une fibromyalgie la maladie
de crohn
salmonellose un caillot sanguin une
gastro-entérite une embolie pulmonaire
à la lecture de ce n'est donc pas
réglé ce repas on achète pas perdu
connaissance sa propre activité akasaka
le texte adopté
elle a rappelé on a l'exemple
ap après la rupture d'une ligne
d'accord pour abolir tous les goûts ce
n'est pas acceptable
el-bachir les autrichiens important de
l'année pour autant entrer dans le
délire en fait c'est très bien fait et
même pas pour des modalités d'aidés
de l'état est tout proche de 100% le
port pendant de longues minutes et
après tu comprends pourquoi de
polémiquer mais pourquoi des débuts
qui peuvent jouer soit une perte de
repères et de bamako
c'est vrai qu'avant la crise les
invités a privé dans une prochaine
vidéo sur internet surtout par peur